qual è la prima immagine che vi viene in
mente se io vi dico interazione uomo
robot come vi immaginate un robot
interattivo scommetto che la maggior
parte di noi pensa a qualcosa del genere
un robot che vive con noi un robot che
ci aiuta un rogo che porta fuori il cane
che magari accompagna i figli a scuola
che fa la spesa
insomma il tipico robot che la tv le
serie tv la fantascienza ci hanno
insegnato ad amare ma è questa la nostra
realtà di tutti i giorni
direi di no purtroppo infatti se andiamo
a pensare qual è la cosa più vicina a un
robot che troviamo nelle nostre case
oggi è questa eh sì è un robot da cucina
non lo definirei proprio robot in realtà
è più un elettrodomestico non troppo
dissimile da una lavatrice o forse una
lavastoviglie
insomma quando dobbiamo interagire con
un robot da cucina
in realtà dobbiamo usarlo siamo noi che
dobbiamo imparare il suo linguaggio e
utilizzare le funzionalità
questo è il robot da cucina che noi
vorremmo con robot abbastanza
intelligente da sbrigarsela ai fornelli
da solo ma che allo stesso tempo possa
condividere con me la cucina sto
cucinando io posso aspettarmi che mi
passi l'utensile giusto al momento
giusto che mi aiuti in pratica senza
grosse difficoltà bene come messa
l'industria robotica nel darci quello
che desideriamo in termini di robot
ossia dei robot che siano abbastanza
intelligenti da cavarsela
ma che allo stesso tempo siano molto
bravi a interagire con noi non si può
negare che l'industria robotica abbia
fatto enormi passi avanti pensiamo ad
alcuni ambiti come l'industria
elettronica all industria
automobilistica
ebbene ci sono ampi rifarti di lavoro
che sono completamente demandate ai
robot che cosa vuol dire che ci sono
robot abbastanza intelligenti da
cavarsela da soli nel realizzare
tipicamente le parti più difficili
pericolose ripetitive del lavoro bene
quindi dato intelligenza possiamo
ritenerci abbastanza soddisfatti ma
l'app l'interazione poi fare un piccolo
gioco con voi vorrei che provate a
guardare nella figura le mie spalle
se riuscite a trovare dove sono gli
operai in mani per alzata di mano
quanti di voi li hanno visti bravi non
era un compito semplicissimo perché in
realtà
ora come ora il problema
dell'interazione non è del tutto risolto
cosa vuol dire che abbiamo i robot che
fanno il loro lavoro
abbiamo gli operai umani che fanno il
loro lavoro il problema è che non si
sfrutta proprio l'interazione come la
intendiamo noi non c'è un robot che
lavora con l'essere umano perché perché
l'interazione uomo macchina a volte è
difficile
pensiamo alla nostra esperienza persona
quanto tempo abbiamo perso sui manuali
di istruzioni per usare una lavatrice e
io scommetto con voi che voi come me non
sapete ancora utilizzare tutte le
funzionalità del vostro telefonino o del
vostro forno a microonde
ecco se è così difficile per rapportarsi
ed utilizzare uno strumento
relativamente semplice come un forno
pensate di scalare questa difficoltà
all'uso di un robot così complesso come
quello che noi sogniamo impossibile
ed è qui che viene il sogno un desiderio
che voglio condividere con voi oggi
io vorrei che i robot del futuro invece
di essere l'ennesimo tour l'ennesimo
strumento l'ennesimo elettrodomestico da
imparare ad utilizzare diventino dei
veri e propri collaboratori bene mi
direte voi
facile no non è facile lo so è stato il
sogno di molti non solo ricercatori
anche scrittori di fantascienza
però io oggi voglio condividere con voi
un'ispirazione che penso possa essere
nuova quella che ritengo possa essere
una chiave per capire meglio come
realizzare questa interazione naturale e
la portata oggi con me sul palco ed è
qui ho anche qui work in progress
si tratta della mia bimba nascerà fra
circa dieci giorni e grazie
al di là dell'amore di mamma come
pensare una cosa del genere un bambino
così piccolo essere la chiave per
risolvere questo problema annoso perché
i bambini anche se sembrano degli esseri
semplici in realtà sono delle macchine
per l'interazione lo sapete che un
bambino appena nato è in grado di capire
se lo state guardando negli occhi o se
invece state guardando altrove
e a poche ore dalla nascita è anche in
grado di stabilire se ciò che si muove
di fronte a lui si sta muovendo di molto
biologico cioè un agente una persona o
un oggetto meno interessante cosa vuol
dire che noi nasciamo predisposti per
interagire con le altre persone e questa
capacità cresce con l'età
velocissimamente pensate prima del primo
anno di età quindi prima ancora che un
bambino impari a parlare è già
bravissimo a collaborare a collaborare
con gli altri bambini con noi adulti a
competere
insomma è già bravissimo a interagire
senza bisogno di parole e questa
capacità di interagire senza bisogno di
linguaggio è una cosa che ci portiamo
anche nell'età adulta è vero quando
parliamo di collaborare la prima cosa
che ci viene in mente è la parola ma
pensiamo a una collaborazione che
funziona il meccanico con il suo
aiutante
se ci pensate quando sono ben assemblati
sono perfettamente in grado di
interagire e collaborare senza bisogno
di tanti discorsi un gesto un'occhiata è
più che sufficiente e l'aiutante passa
l'utensile giusto al momento giusto
perché perché la nostra comunicazione
non è fatta di parole non soltanto ma di
una miriade
di segnali e questi segnali sono non
verbali e legati alle nostre azioni ha
come nuovo le mani a come li muovono
nello spazio acqua nuovo gli occhi ma
questa non è un'idea nuova
c'era già arrivato darwin parecchio
tempo fa cosa diceva diceva che quando
si tratta di trasmettere o di capire le
intenzioni e le mozioni di qualcun altro
ebbene un'azione può valere mille
immagini mille parole
e la cosa interessante per me è che
mette tra un uomo e una macchina
la cosa difficile è stabilire una
comunicazione per noi uomini comunicare
così facile che la cosa difficile è
limitare la comunicazione vi faccio un
esempio
pensate a un tavolo dei giocatori di
poker notate nulla di strano
nell'immagine alle mie spalle
questi buy tp non stanno certo
indossando gli occhiali da sole per
proteggersi dalle luci al neon della
saga stanno cercando di proteggersi
dalla comunicazione implicita sanno
benissimo che basterebbe uno schiaccia
troppo veloce
un tremolio della mano nel raggiungere
il mazzo di carte e tutti gli altri
sarebbero informati del loro stato
d'animo delle loro emozioni
in quel momento di quanto è buono il
mazzo di carte la mano di carte che
hanno e stanno giocando e ovviamente
qualcosa che non vogliono bene questa
comunicazione fortissima naturale e
semplice assolutamente non faticosa
questa è quella che io vorrei il sogno
per me il mio robot bene mi direte la
strada allora non è così difficile
tu hai già un esempio che puoi copiare
studiano mettilo sotto robot
e a posto così ciao ma per studiare
qualsiasi fenomeno fisico sociale è
molto importante poterlo controllare se
io lo posso controllare allora posso
creare degli stimoli ripetibili e vedere
modificandoli l'effetto che hanno a
questo punto li posso modellare capire
quantitativamente e allora sì immetterli
sul mio robot ma come vi dicevo noi
uomini non siamo bravi a controllare la
comunicazione implicita pensateci anche
gli attori o i politici cioè persone che
sanno benissimo quanto sia importante
controllare la comunicazione talvolta
non ce la fanno e sentono una spinta
insostenibile a comunicare qualcosa che
forse non avrebbero dovuto comunicare
quindi noi non abbiamo il controllo
completo su questi meccanismi
perché sono inconsci in grande parte
come fare allora a studiarli ecco qui la
mia proposta
utilizziamo i robot perché perché il
robot prima ancora di diventare il
compagno o meglio dire il collaboratore
che tutti noi segniamo può esserci già
molto utile come strumento di indagine
perché il robot può interagire con noi
possiamo giocare insieme sul touchscreen
ad esempio mai un robot possiamo
controllare
esattamente
in maniera ripetibile come si muove come
muove le mani come modo gli occhi ea
quel punto possiamo effettivamente
misurare qual è l'impatto di questi
comportamenti sulla persona che gioca
con lui questa è la strategia che vi
propongo oggi per cercare di capire come
noi esseri umani riusciamo a trasformare
ogni nostra azione in una forma di
comunicazione perché dico questo perché
vi faccio un esempio banale
lì c'è un frigo io vada dal frigo
apro il frigo tirò fuori il cartone del
latte è vero passo molto semplice azione
banale con uno scopo molto chiaro
passarvi di cartone del latte bene
nell'esecuzione di quest'azione io senza
pensarci è rivelato anche un
informazione
voi sapete subito dirmi se il cartone
del latte è pieno e vuoto è una cosa
semplicissima però attraverso questa
azione io vi ho anche comunicato
qualcosa che altrimenti per voi sarebbe
stato del tutto invisibile ed è questo
passaggio segreto di informazioni
secondo me quello che rende la nostra
collaborazione con altre persone così
immediata semplice tra cui quello che
sto cercando di fare è di vedere se
riusciamo a rendere anche i robot dei
veri e propri comunicatori con le loro
azioni e quindi ad esempio abbiamo
cercato di rendere questo robot umanoide
è in grado non solo di svolgere azioni
utili come prendere una bambina
degli oggetti oppure passarci degli
oggetti ma allo stesso tempo abbiamo
studiato dove nella sua azione si
nascondeva l'informazione e adesso
quando il robot ci passa un oggetto noi
sappiamo magicamente anziché peso e
quindi siamo pronti a riceverlo bene ma
questa solo una faccia della medaglia
perché perché la comunicazione di per sé
è bidirezionale non ci basta comunicare
quando noi ci muoviamo noi vogliamo che
robot capisca anche noi che ci muoviamo
deve essere anche un lettore
allora abbiamo cercato di modellare che
questa capacità la capacità di leggere
le nostre azioni e abbiamo deciso di
partire dagli occhi perché gli occhi ben
si dice spesso gli occhi sono lo
specchio dell'anima la porta dell'anima
ed è effettivamente vero io muovo gli
occhi per guardarmi intorno
ma se voi guardate dove sto guardando
capite subito dove rivolta alla mia
attenzione
ecco dotando il robot di questa capacità
l'abbiamo reso collaboratore vi faccio
vedere un piccolo esempio in questo
piccolo video ci siamo io e il robot che
stiamo cercando di aiutare il nostro
amico a montare una pila di cubetti
come vedete in ogni istante siamo in
grado di capire sia io sia il robot se
il mio turno ho il suo e in quale dei
due cubetti che abbiamo in mano
dobbiamo passare al nostro amico bene in
questo caso siamo stati dei buoni
collaboratori vi rivelo però un piccolo
dietro le qui
in questo video il robot non capiva
un'acca d'inglese 0 e non guardava
nemmeno le mani del nostro amico
niente lui monitorava soltanto i
movimenti dei suoi occhi e nonostante
questo è riuscito a rispondere al volo
alle sue esigenze e diventare un vero e
proprio collaboratore bene mi rendo
conto queste sono solo piccoli passi
però secondo me sono piccoli passi nella
giusta direzione
nel tentativo di rendere l'interazione
con i robot naturale un po quel tipo di
interazione che il cinema c'è da sempre
fatto sognare però il cinema ha sempre
fregato ha usato scorciatoie cos'ha
fatto
ha preso un bucchi robotici e ci ha
infilato dentro persone umane 30 anni fa
come due anni fa
ecco io mi propongo di fare esattamente
l'opposto ossia di prendere un robot e
metterlo nell'interazione perché solo
così possiamo studiare in maniera
quantitativa come avviene questa
incredibile naturale collaborazione ed è
così che io spero che si realizza il mio
desiderio è che cioè nel prossimo futuro
in ciascuna delle nostre case ci sia un
robot che non sia l'ennesimo
elettrodomestico ma un vero e proprio
collaboratore
vi ringrazio